منتشر على كل المنصات تحذيرات من جهاز
جالسبينجال نقادر على ثقه بيانات وكلمات
سر اي بطاقه او هاتف بمجرد المرور من
جانبها وطبعا الجهاز عامل حاله من او عام
الحاله من الذعر عند الكل وطبعا ترى حاله
الرعب هذه العالميه وعلى تيك توك تحديدا
بدات الفيديوهات بالانتشار ومن هناك
انتقلت لباقي من الصوت
والهاشتاج على تيك توك على النصف مليار
مشاهده بكل اللغات والعربي منها كمان طبعا
شوفوا بعض المقاطع اللي بتتكلم عن الجهاز
وبتحضر منه
يعتبر هذا الجهاز من اخطر اجهزه التهكير
اللي ترعبك وتدعي لك حرفيا بنفس الوقت
وانا هذا الفيديو لاسباب تعليميه فقط
والغريب ان هذا الجهاز متوفر في المتاجر
ومتناول يد الجميع طبعا هذا الجهاز اسمه
فليبر زيرو اول ما تشوفه حسب اللعبه ولكن
لا تنخدع بالمظاهر لان هذا الجهاز جهاز
دمار شامل اقصد جهاز تعليمي متعدد المهام
اغلبكم الحين يتساءل ايش يقدر عليه هذا
الجهاز هذا الجهاز يقدر ينسخ الاشاره في
النطاق اللي موجود فيه ينسخ الاشاره ويفتح
ابواب السيارات والانفسي والابواب سياره
والبطائق البنكيه الجوالات المغلقه او
الحسابات وحتى التلفزيونات وغيرها كثير
اداء فعلا
[موسيقى]
اغرب اختراع ظهر لنا في 20 23 ولكن اتصدمت
لما لقيت ان الفيديو جاب اكثر من 36 مليون
مشاهده والعدد ده بسبب الاختراع اللي اسمه
واللي اول ما هتشوفه هتفتكره جهاز اتاري
ولكن هو اكثر من كده ظهرت فيديوهات كثير
لنسبه تستخدمه في فتح لاوض الموجوده في
الفنادق وفتح العربيات وكمان تشغيل
التليفزيونات بالاضافه لانه يقدر ينسخ
الكروت البنكيه وتدفع من خلاله وكل ده لان
معتمد على احدث تقنيات الاي اي
[موسيقى]
مثل ما شفتوا الجهاز اسمه فليبر زيرو وهو
جهاز متوفر للبيع على امازون وباقي
المتاجر الالكترونيه وباسعار رخيصه جدا
على فكره يعني والجهاز بيجمع تقنيات اجهزه
اخرى عديده وقادر على انه يصير جهاز واحد
عنده اكسس على ريموتات اي اجهزه فمثلا
الجهاز هذا ممكن من خلاله تفتح السياره
تشغل المكيف والتليفزيون والبيت وغيرها
وكمان ممكن يعمل سكان للهويه الشخصيه
وبطاقات التعريف وبنجال انه كمان بمجرد
مرور ومن جنب اي جهاز تليفون ممكن ينسخ كل
الكلمات السر لاي برامج او من الصاج بما
فيها كلمات سر البنوك والبطاقات البنكيه
كمان مع حاله الدعاء الشديد اللي عملها
الجهاز بين الناس على المنصات طلع مغتصين
ومنهم هكذا محترفين
ومتخصصين وقالوا يا جماعه بطلوا مبالغه
الكلام هذا مو صحيح وما في جهاز ممكن يعمل
كل هذا
صحيح وايش الحقيقه حول هذا الجهاز خلينا
نفهم اكثر لما نسال طبعا مختص بينضم الينا
من الرياض خبير الامن السيبراني محمد علي
الغامدي اهلا فيك معنا يا محمد همم انت
جالس بتضحك هل بتضحك لانه الجهاز فعلا
خطير ولازم تحذرنا منه ولا لان الناس
بتبالغ
حياك الله اهلا بالعزيزه ساره
لانه الزخم الاعلامي الموجود على وهم
يخلقه الخوف من السرقه ومن بعض الادوات
اللي الناس يشوفونها كنا سحر همم
صوصيه اللي انت من وجهه نظرك عليها طيب
اول شيء هذا الجهاز هو اتصنع ليش يعني ايش
الهدف منه
طيب الجهاز ما في اي شيء جديد الجهاز كل
الاشياء اللي فيه موجوده اوريدي في اجهزه
والاجهزه هذه يمكن بعضها عمرها 10 سنوات
او اكثر من 10 سنوات طيب الحلو المميز في
هذا الجهاز انه يجمع هذا كل كل الخواص
التقنيه هذه في جهاز واحد
اللي هي ايش هذه الخواتم
طيب بشكل عام اممم التحكم
بالترددات الراديويه
نسخها حفظها وكتابتها ولكنها فعاله فقط
على بروتوكولات قديمه لا تستخدم في او ضمن
الاجهزه الحساسه او نقول البروتوكولات
الحساسه جدا مثل اجهزه فك ال ال او
الريموتات الخاصه بفك السيارات
بكل اللي يسويه الجهاز بشكل فعلي هو نسخ
تردد حفظه
وارساله او كتابته على جهاز اخر بالاضافه
الى خاصيه اسمها باديو اس بي هذه نوع من
انواع الاتات او نوع من انواع الهجمات
الالكترونيه اللي قد تستخدم لزرع اكواد
خبيثه اذا كان متصل باجهزه لكن مره اخرى
بعد خاصيه موجوده في جهاز اطلق في 2012 اه
وكثير في بروتوكولات الحمايه من مثل هذا
الخصيه
ايش قصدك بانه بياخذ تردد
امم اغلب الوايرلس كونيكشنز اللي يصير في
حياتنا زي فتح المكيف تغيير القنوات من
خلال جهاز التحكم بال تي في همم وما الى
ذلك تصير عن طريق موجات راديويه همم
تردد موجود على تردد معين همم نفس الشيء
موجود في الجهاز وهم انه ينسخ يخزن ويقدر
كمان يكتب الان الناس بتنزل فيديوهات
وبتنزل وفي منهم حتى يعني خبراء في
التقنيه وكاتبين فيه مواقع يعني هي معروفه
من مواقع التقنيه بيقولوا انه الا فعلا
جربوا الجهاز والجهاز النسخ المعلومات حق
الباسوردات والاشياء هذه كلها
طيب في اشياء الجهاز مستحيل يسويها مهما
يعني
قالوها خاصه تقنيه ما تاهله ااا ولانو هذا
الشمس مستحيل تصيروا بشكل وايرلس اول شيء
نسخ كلمات السر الخاصه بحسابات
نسخ كلمات السر الخاصه بالبنوك
نسخ اي شيء من الجوال
اذا الا في حاله انه الجهاز كان موصل بي
usb في الجوال والجوال كان مسمو يعني يسمح
للجهاز انه يقدر يدخل وياخذ اكسس عليه
يقدر الجهاز وقته انه هو يزرع كود خبيث
ويتحكم بمحتم بالجواله ومحتويات الجوال
بالكامل
عدا او غير ذلك الجهاز يعني فعليا الشيء
المميزه الوحيد في انه يجمع خواص لاجهزه
كثيره
بيعدوا من جنب الشخص وبياخذه الباسوردات
طيب كيف تفسر هذه الفيديوهات اللي شايفين
نشوفها على تيك توك ايش بيصير
بيكذبوا علينا يعني
طيب انا ما ادري اي فيديو تحديدا تقولين
عليه لكن اقدر البنوك مثلا
هذا غير صحيح ابدا الجهاز اذا مررت فيه
على بطاقه فيزا مثلا بينسخ الايدي الخاص
بالبطاقه لكن مستحيل ينسخ اي معلومات اخرى
والاي دي هذا لحاله غير مفيد ومستحيل احد
استخدمه عشان يسرق فلوس او ما له ذلك
مره اخرى
شف لنا فيديوهات ثانيه كمان يعني برده
مقلقه يعني لما انا اقدر مثلا انه اتحكم
في انه مثلا جراج احد ينفتح ولا ما ينفتح
لان انا مثلا ادخل مطعم وفجاه التصفي لهم
الاضاءه بالجهاز يعني هذه كلها اشياء
خطيره الصراحه برده
صحيح اتفق معك هذا شيء صحيح الجهاز يسويها
لانه اغلب الاجهزه هذه لها ريموتات
والريموتات لها ترددات وغالبا غير امنه
ومالها بروتوكولات معينه للحمايه من قبل
اجهزه قد تنسخ الترددات هذه وتقوم باعاده
ارسالها فصحيح هذا الشيء موجود الشيء
الوحيد اللي نقدر نحنا نسويه عشان نتلاقى
مثل هذا الحوادث انه اللهم نستخدم اجهزه
لها خلينا نقول بروتوكولات امن همم سواء
خاصه بالكراج او خاصه يعني الجهاز يستخدم
او فعال على اجهزه لا تستخدم بروتوكولات
قديمه فغالبا هذا الاجهزه رخيصه همم لكن
في اجهزه اخرى يعني تستخدم نوع من انواع
تشالنج خلينا نقول في عمليه همم ارسال
واستقبال الترددات الخاصه
والتتيح للجهاز انه يفتح او يقفل همم
هذه الاجهزه
من قديمه او مش عارفه ايه بس مثلا هذا
الشيماء بينطبق على مثلا سيارات تسلا
سيارات تسلا اللي يصير في سيارات تسلا انا
اللي شفته انه الجهاز يفتح همم المدخل حق
الشحن
والصندوق وهذه
ايوه وهذه وهذه خاصيه موجوده في اي شاحن
كهربائي اذا اخذتي اي شاحن اذا عندك سياره
تسله رحت عند اي شاحن كهربائي متسله وقدمت
راس الشاحن قريب من ال- من الفتحه
يفتحها حق الصندوق تردد موجود ما له اي
حمايه لانه اعتقدت الشركه انه ما يحتاج
حمايه وكثير شركات تقدر تصنيع نفس هذا
الانبوب تقدر تفتح فيه فتحه الشحن الخاصه
بالسياره
انت بتقول ما يقدر ينقل المعلومات البنكيه
وما يقدر ياخذ الباسوردات لكن اذا الانسان
او شخص قرر يستخدم بطريقه فيها اذيه الناس
ثانيين او مثلا ضرر لهم من ناحيه انه
يتحكم في محلات اضاءه تكييف ما نعرفهاش
يقدر يتحكم بهذا الشيء
حيقدر ياذيهم
عم يقدر
يسوي هذا الشيء ليش لانه هذا الاضاءه او
هذا التلفزيون
محمد علي الغامدي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]